You've been following the news Bill
Gross the Bond King Who left pimco on
September 26 to Join Janice Capital We
Just Found out that in the month of
September the Fund the unconstrained
Bond Fund that Bill Gross will be
managing at Janice Capital received 66.4
Million  in client deposits This is
according to Morningstar 66 Million is a
fraction Remember The Bill Gross overs
the Total Return Fund Which at the time
of his Departure had billion asss and as
the Chief investment officer at pco he
oversaw some 1.9 trillion nevertheless
Gross announced his Departure  from pimco
on the 26th he didn't Start at Janice
until September the 29th and he didn't
In fact Start managing Money at Janice
until this past Monday so the money Is
Coming in trickling in For The Moment at
least according to these figures for
Morning Star 66 Million of client
deposits into Bill Gross New Fund